[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
online stuff being as it is sometimes
there's that for the race if you go to
the congressman's website and there's
Twitter account actually you can see
that full race up for itself from
Louisiana will hear from Leo on our
independent line hi leo good morning
the non-integral you know Pedro there is
biblical scripture that says the troops
he'll set you free
I have polled about between 30 and 34
Trump supporters calls and not one
stands up on the truth I am a military
veteran
I am african-american and male and I can
tell you that Barack Obama because he is
african-american and male did very
little or nothing for veterans or
nothing for black people now that is the
truth that statistically the truth you
do not hear that from Trump supporters
even though he is dead wrong you do not
hear that from your supporters and you I
an American know always that the truth
will set you free I again I want to
reiterate I am a military veteran I am
African American in meal Barack Obama
did nothing for veterans he did nothing
for people of my color you do not hear
that from the Donald Trump supporters
okay so I come in let's go to North
Carolina we'll hear from Mary on our
Republican line I'm Mary Mary from
Pinehurst North Carolina
one more time for Mary okay
so we'll show you the story from The
Washington Times of Tom how jr. talking
about the Congressional Budget Office
and what would happen if the individual
mandate for Obamacare was repealed their
estimations the savings of three hundred
thirty eight billion dollars those
report also adding that premiums would
rise an average of ten percent in most
years of the coming decade because
healthier people would be less likely to
buy insurance once they're no longer
forced to the office said the resulting
rate hikes would chase more people away
leading to the drop of 13 million the
individual mandate is the most unpopular
part of the 2020 2010 health law through
President Obama included to spur enough
healthy people to the market to balance
out sicker customers who could no longer
be denied coverage repealing the
provision would erase its tax revenue
you know to actually save money over
time because fewer people would see
coverage and draw taxpayer-funded
subsidies that defrayed their premiums
Sheila is in Washington DC independent
line good morning yes good morning to
you the reason for my call this morning
is that I wanted to address some of the
colors that we're calling in um the one
thing I love about this ban is that you
can call and give your opinions but just
because you can call and give your
opinion doesn't mean that their facts
and I've heard a lot of let's say fake
facts that were given this morning and
one of the things that I do regardless
of who I'm listening to whether it's CNN
fox or MSNBC is that I go out and check
politically fact to see if or yeah to
see if it's true or not and there has
been more Wars started under the
Republican presidents
then you know Democrats there have been
more military deaths under Republican
presidents there has been under
Democrats and I really think that
regardless of who you listen to or who
chickens from you should always question
always that information out for yourself
before you hear something and they just
go and repeat it and that's what I
wanted to share this night let's go to
trout ville Virginia and we'll hear from
John Democrats line yes good morning
tiger oh yes I just want to comment on
we keep hearing from our president that
this is all a wild goose chase and
there's nothing there's a witch-hunt
well every time we turn around some new
person pops up met with the Russians
even though it's all them denied and
told there's nothing there but every day
is you drip drip drip more people and
you know you just can't say fake news
every time something comes up when it
just looks like it's true so you know I
just don't understand how his president
can get by with this thank you John is
last call in Virginia last story comes
from the Chicago Tribune this morning
about former President Obama taking on a
new role that of a member of a jury at
least reporting for jury duty the paper
reports that he won two presidential
elections and a Nobel Peace Prize on
Wednesday the former leader of the free
world performed the unthinkable he made
Cook County jury excited Duty exciting
the prospective juror Barack Obama who
was ultimately not chosen to sit on the
jury climbed out of an SUV in a parking
garage and he was company by the Secret
Service he wrote a private elevator to
the judges for the elevator that was
reserved for judges and he was greeted
by the judge he also greeted others
we're waiting to see if they were going
to serve as Judy jury duty the paper
reporting that he emerged smiling as if
the campaign mode shaking hands as he
made his way under the fluorescent
lights to the jury assembly room that's
on the Chicago Tribune's website by the
way last story for this hour one more
hour so this program left the house
coming in at nine o'clock today coming
up we're going to speak with Congressman
Tom Garrett of Virginia a discussion on
homeland security policy following the
attacks in New York and Texas later on
the program will be joined by longtime
journalist Dan Rather on his new book
what unites us Washington Journal
after this
[Music]
Sunday night on afterwards it was
imperative for me because I had a
platform and that this is my 15 minutes
then Here I am and if I I'm here today
I'm not speaking on behalf of the FBI my
speaking on behalf of any Intelligence
Agency and I'm not speaking on behalf of
anybody but myself but I would like to
say that I hope and pray that I am
speaking on behalf of the millions of
Muslim Americans and of 1.7 billion
across the globe that don't think
radically I want them to feel
comfortable and stand up and say that is
not the religion that is what's being
warped by al Qaeda and Isis they're not
the only ones with the voice anymore and
that's why gold Muslim American federal
agent tammer al nouri who requested to
remain anonymous talks about his
experience fighting domestic terrorism
in America with his book American
radical inside the world of an
undercover Muslim FBI agent he's
interviewed by Michael German author of
thinking like a terrorist in sights of a
former FBI undercover agent watch
afterwards Sunday night at 9:00 Eastern
on c-span to's book TV
this week on Q&A we look at the lies of
the eight Jewish justices who've served
on the Supreme Court our guest is David
Allen author of Jewish justices of the
Supreme Court one of the themes of my
book actually is the declining
anti-semitism within the American legal
profession from the time of Brandeis and
kodos o to Ruth Bader Ginsburg and
Breyer and Kagan but McReynolds was
notoriously
anti-semitic that I was going to mention
that famous portrait in 1924 in which he
did a set for but when he when from his
vantage point Hoover had the audacity to
a dominate Cardozo he wrote a letter on
his own stationery to Hoover saying how
dare you afflict the court with another
Hebrew Sunday night at 8:00 Eastern on
c-span's Q&A
Washington Journal continues we're
joined by representative Tom Garrett
republican of virginia and a member of
the Foreign Affairs and homeland
security committees good morning good
morning and let's not give short shrift
to admin workforce thank you for that
violent events in New York and Texas
over the last few weeks talk about those
events particularly what it means in
terms of homeland security here in the
United States well I don't think we need
reminders you know we got Vegas as well
that we're very vulnerable here at home
the nature of a free society is such
that there will inherently be some risk
our job is to mitigate and reduce that
risk to the best of our ability I will
tell you without delving into areas
where I can't go that there are
shortcomings and our defenses in any
number of areas whether it's flight
safety which you think you know sixteen
years post September eleventh we've
gotten straight with the cyber realm is
something that is really a new paradigm
as it relates to that so we have to be
ever vigilant we have to understand that
the bad things are going to happen in a
free society but we should do everything
we can to mitigate and reduce those and
so when it comes to the specific
incidents themselves say when it comes
to the Texas shooting there's this whole
conversation about the kind of
information that ends up on these
databases where people get approved for
guns right do you think there's
improvements need is that and it's that
openness needed it's that's not the
first shooter recently who was banned
from possessing firearms who possess
firearms and you could always make the
argument that anyone who's willing to
take a human life will break whatever
gun laws there are but regardless we
need to have the gun laws that we have
be enforced adequately and so there's a
real dropping of the ball by the Air
Force by the FBI by the processing
entities now I've ironically in Virginia
I think Virginia is one of only two
states that still has a state background
check on top of the federal background
check I've argued against it in the
redundancy thereof having said that in
this circumstance perhaps the failure to
catch it on one would have been caught
on the other but you know there's a
mental health problem in this country
and that individual I will not call him
a gentleman that individual should have
never been anywhere near firearms
was prohibited under law how come our
laws didn't work and so there needs to
be some soul-searching expand on that
redundancy issue when a level of
redundancy be a good thing to happen
these kind of channel it is unless
you're the individual who's availing
themselves of their right to possess a
firearm right I mean so that plus any
government redundancy cost taxpayers
twice right having said that again
we know that this person was forbidden
on a number of levels dishonorable
discharge crime of domestic violence I'm
not sure how he didn't pick up a felony
in the airforce based on as I understand
it fracturing the skull of a toddler so
while I would argue against redundancy
because it's wasteful of the limited
assets of the taxpayer why did the
system not work
and I can assure you there are people
looking into that it would be
accountability is always a good thing I
think it discourages bad outcomes in the
future so as the incident Texas in Las
Vegas opened up new avenues for a
discussion on gun related issues and gun
ownership issues well it certainly will
whether we like it or not all right
there are people who are reflexively
going to go there having said that we
live in a country where the number of
firearms arguably is greater than the
number of human beings and any sort of
confiscatory rollback would ensure that
law-abiding citizens turned in their
firearms and those who don't obey the
law don't and I don't you know I'm not a
mathematician but I would wager that
there would be millions and millions of
firearms still in circulation and we
would have essentially disarmed those
who've done nothing to lose the right
the natural law right to defend
themselves and their families right so
you know we're going there whether we
like it or not I think that disarming
law-abiding citizens doesn't solve the
problem the other thing is and this is
very noteworthy long guns shotguns and
rifles I think I think a responsible ask
FBI statistic for about 2.7 percent of
homicides which means we're sitting at
ninety seven point three percent and
you're more likely to be killed with a
knife with hands and feet with a blunt
object like a club and when we see these
mass shootings certainly it's tragic and
horrific but the instrumentality of evil
as we learned in New York yet again
might be any number of things and and
and the vast bulk of America
we're endowed by their creator with the
right to defend themselves or their
families and the most efficient way to
do that in a world of people who might
be bigger or stronger or younger or
healthier than you is usually a firearm
so we're gonna have the gun control talk
I don't think the disarming law-abiding
citizens is the right answer to
criminals I think we really have a
mental health crisis in this country
that we failed to address and we need to
really look at Tom Garrett our guest for
the next twenty minutes or so and if you
want to ask him questions two oh two
seven four eight eight thousand four
Democrats 202 semper 88,000 one for
Republicans independents 202 seven four
eight eight thousand to being a member
of these committees of Foreign Affairs
and Homeland Security you mentioned the
New York incident where are we in
investigating that well we've learned
some relatively disturbing things about
when alarm bells do and do not go off
that's echoed in the New York case and
in other cases recently and there are
certain things that I'm not at liberty
to discuss on the air but you could make
an argument that this gentleman this guy
sorry
shouldn't has an offense to gentleman
everywhere that this guy should have
been on somebody's radar that maybe uber
knew that he was a shady character
before the federal government did having
said that you know I think it was I'm
not sure who it was in the previous
administrator or the administration
before that said that we have to be
wrong once and they have to be right
once we can be right 99.9% of time the
question then becomes what degree of
scrutiny American citizens will tolerate
having themselves subjected to certainly
this gentleman was here illegally we can
discuss the merits of diversity visas if
you want but is there a merit to a
diversity visa we should have people
immigrating to this country you bring
something to the table regardless of
what they look like how they worship or
where they from but we have problems in
America right now that we I think failed
to address we look the other way on
profits pending a debt that's gone from
5.3 trillion
ten years ago to 20 trillion now and so
our I would I would argue that our
immigration policy should be conducted
like a professional sports team conducts
the draft
that we should have a healthy and robust
admissions process but we should hope
that we admit people who will be net
contributors from the get-go that nobody
has a monopoly on a good idea is that
there are people who can generate
economic activity and growth and and
help keep America at the head of the
idea war right we what we do better than
anyone else in the world is come up with
ideas we don't perfect stuff necessarily
but they're usually our ideas having
said that though if you're not
proficient in English if you don't have
a skill set that makes you a commodity
and demand goodness knows there are any
number of people who'd love to be here
and I would submit that that those are
the folks that we should focus on
allowing to avail themselves of the
amazing gift that is US citizenship
calls for you are lined up we start with
our Republican line this is Meridian
Mississippi Walter you're on with our
guest representative Tom Garrett of
Virginia good morning go ahead yeah how
y'all doing this morning
yeah my question is do you really think
that you could uh if this fella would
have been on all kind of radar and the
laws at a pass and if they repeated data
if they would have I'm kind of nervous
if they were to do a caller we'll leave
it there we'll take your portion and let
our guests respond I think I think we're
Walter was going was that bad people are
gonna do bad things regardless there's
probably some degree of truth to that
that doesn't absolve us of our
responsibility to try to protect the
American people but again I think the
answer is not denying Americans
fundamental rights the answer is not
building up a super surveillance state
that that prized into our reasonable
expectations of privacy there's a
balancing act somewhere and I'm gonna
stand for liberty whenever I can I'm
gonna stand against government intrusion
into your private life where I can and I
do believe that as it relates to
firearms we have a right not bestowed
upon us by the government but by our
Creator or nature whatever your value
system says to defend ourselves that you
know tell me that it's okay to tell the
woman being a sale by a violent attacker
the
she doesn't have the right to shoot him
from Texas City Texas Democrats line ron
is next congressman I assume as
conservative Republican you were very
much in favor of Bowe Bergdahl were
receiving those full impact of Military
Justice because not only did he he
abandoned his fellow troops but he was
other troops to be killed or injured
trying to to rescue him because they
they thought he'd been kidnapped
they actually found out what happened so
I'm assuming your answer to that
question is yes and so therefore would
you insist on Military Justice
investigation and complete military
justice for whoever in the Air Force
failed to pass on the information about
the domestic abuse associated with the
individual killed all those people in
southern range okay caller thank you
yeah I think he makes a very good point
we are trying to understand where the
breakdowns occurred I think there was an
error on the reporting portion of the
Air Forces responsibility but I also
believe there may have been an error at
the FBI I do think people should be held
accountable I don't think that we should
be pursuing prison sentences for someone
who made a clerical error but they might
ought to lose their job right I mean
it's absolutely horrific to contemplate
the results of that mistake but it
wasn't with intent that they did that
back to Bergdahl I think your caller
properly assumes my position there
having served in the military I have to
believe that the judge you made the
ruling never spent one day in the combat
arms unit but went straight in the Jag
Corps for whatever because I don't think
he understands what the women and men on
the frontlines go through and I will
tell you that if I were to give my true
feelings on Bo Bergdahl it would be
beneath the dignity of the office of
Congress our guests served in active
duty as an artillery officer for six
years he was a brigade operations
officers and operations joint guard and
Joint Endeavor Tulsa Oklahoma Republican
line Trevor go ahead good morning first
I'd like to thank you for for your
guests for standing up for liberty both
on the battlefield in there in Congress
it's very refreshing my comment is on on
gun control and opioids kind of both
it's I think it's a result of our
society getting so soft these people
that can't take a little bit of just
discomfort or pain I think real life is
just too hard and then they got to go
out and do something ignorant and evil
and I think that if people knew how to
cope with just regular things it mean
used to cope with without you know
shooting 26 people that a we want to
have this it has much less to do with
the size of a magazine or your semiotic
semi-automatic rifle well you you know
Gandhi said man cannot be made good by
law and if you just sort of sit and
contemplate that for a moment the
brilliance of it is isn't simplicity we
have a real problem
I will not begin to judge the individual
whose is prescribed opioids I don't
understand what pain drives them to that
point and so therefore I won't judge
with that broad brush having said that
in Germany right now there's a case
involving a nurse who's alleged to have
killed 102 people and we don't know his
last name
we know only his first name because the
German media and and legal system have
decided not to tell us who this person
was
and to some degree when you realize that
your life is not going perhaps where you
wanted it to and you're a moral and
without any regard for your fellow man
it might seem appealing to become if you
will famous or noteworthy and that I
think we might should take a page from
the Germans playbook well the American
people absolutely positively have a
right to know all the specificity that
we can but we do not need to make that I
could start naming mass shooters these
people and into anti-heroes that are
that are ingrained in our pop culture
and not blaming anyone just saying maybe
we should take a look at how we do
business from West Virginia independent
line next up Larry
you're on with our guest yes I like to
thank dog s was service to the country
right the state that I went to school in
upstate New York and the school was
closed the first day of hunting season
the school had a rifle team we were able
to bring our rifles on the school bus
when we lived out of town you'd hunt on
your way to school and on your way home
when you got to school you could put
them in your locker
chuckle in the principal's office and no
one in our school ever got shot and
loads of people were on the school buses
and in the school with rifles and we
never had a problem I think it's just a
matter of kids not respecting themselves
or respecting the people around them
they're not respectful life they don't
respect for the teachers they don't
respect for anything is lack of
discipline in our school there was a
dress code you have to have cuffs on the
man's pants they sure had to have a
collar on it the girls had dressed out
of people oh dear me and the girls took
sewing they made their own graduation
gowns didn't have to spend a lot of
money on it and I think it's just a
matter of the school's not really doing
their job they don't think they don't
have discipline in the schools you go
past the schools today the guys going in
look looks like bump their pants are
falling off their asses hanging out okay
caller leave it there I you look I mean
I think it's easy to point a finger at
the schools I think it starts at home on
the school's receive the product that we
send them
I think telling young people that they
have some value and what they look like
and how they present themselves helps
contribute to that might be an
encouragement to get better behavior I
will tell the caller that I didn't grow
up and graduate from high school too
darn long ago and and in Louisa County
Virginia where I went if we're deer
season rabbit season or dove season and
there weren't 150 shotguns in the
parking lot something was wrong and and
nobody ever shot anybody and I do think
he's on to something as it relates to
how we value life and and what's
socially acceptable I mean we had plenty
of fistfights probably more than they
had have today but young people never
thought about going and retrieving a
firearm and turn it on their classmates
and so I don't know what we lost but
it's too easy to say the schools have
failed we are the ones as parents who
put the children in those schools who
seem to be behaving differently but I
believe probably the most articulate
thing ever to come out of george w
bush's mouth is that the the term the
soft bigotry of low expectations I think
we should gently and kindly and firmly
demand more from young people and it
will be shocked when we start to get it
our guest serves the fifth District of
Virginia includes Dansville
let's Vil Warrenton representative Tom
Garrett a member of the Foreign Affairs
and homeland security committees several
months out from the incident in
Charlottesville what's the thing you've
learned most from that whole affair
including the death of that young woman
well what blew my mind was that there
are people who exist in sufficient
numbers to gather in the hundreds who
will judge someone based on what they
look like right wrap your brain around
that I mean a slave owner named
Jefferson gave us a declaration where he
enumerated the concept that all people
were equal so a flawed man gave us a
nearly flawless document 53 years ago in
August dr. King in this city said we
should judge individuals on the content
of the character not to color their skin
I can debate anybody on anything except
if you are so so colored by hate that
you think you can look at another person
or find out where they worship or who
they sleep with or what have you and
then say ah they're better than me or
I'm better than them that is when I saw
that and my father worked for years in
Charlottesville on one of the streets
where this roving sort of melee occurred
when I saw those images and recognized
those areas I couldn't believe that
those people existed in those numbers I
thought the Ku Klux Klan was relegated
to the History Channel now the good news
is it took 40 states worth of miscreants
to create that that size assembly the
bad news is that stuff's real those
people are real the tragic frightening
fact though is that it's colored our
political discourse to the point where I
think we're tearing at the fabric of
this nation by asserting hatred and
animosity where it doesn't exist if you
label anyone who disagrees with you as a
Nazi then what do you do when you find
the real ones and and so what do you
think about the debate that emerges that
about the the anti fob movement their
role in it the equivalence that was
being played yeah I got yelled at and
I'll probably just dissing chance some
people who are my base because my
immediate blame for the deaths was on
their on the Nazis on the KKK
yes antiphon was there yes they acted
like fools as well but the but-for cause
of the assembly that cost the lives not
of one but of three human beings was
these extremists racist individuals
became because they knew that these
clowns were going to be there and so I
think that the first thing that needed
to be done and we were on the air at the
day of the event
condemning full-throated Lee in fact the
first rally in May I think I was the
first elected official to write an
editorial where I said you can talk to
me about free speech all you want but
when you show up wearing all white
carrying torches at night by Confederate
statue I think you might have another
motive where else you failed 8th grade
history so so let's condemn the but-for
cause while acknowledging that antiphon
are very very bad actors we're
antithetical to who we are as a nation
but really the bigger message is that
the vice-president United States Joe
Biden says they want to put you back in
Chains Tom Perez says the Republican
Party doesn't give a expletive deleted
about people the vice presidential
nominee says we must fight them in the
streets and then a week later his sons
arrested for you got christened Jill and
Brandon and Kamla Harris engaging in F
waist-high raids we they stuff look look
we can disagree on tax policy on health
care policy etc without your opponents
being communist or Nazis or fascist
there are real fascists there are real
Nazis and they are a real threat and and
and the the demagoguery and the jingoism
is beneath the dignity of the american
political process and dangerous let's go
to Potomac Maryland Democrats line
Richard you're on with our guest
representative I'd like to congratulate
you for your your heart and you sound
reasonable where do you stop
at allowing weapons do you stop at
bazookas do you stop at automatic
weapons you stop the military style
rifles so I think the Constitution and
the Bill of Rights should be examined in
the context of the events of the time in
which they occurred and so if you ask
yourself honestly what the underlying
cause for the Second Amendment being
included in the Bill of Rights was it
was for the Americans to protect
themselves from a tyrannical government
and that's an easy one to determine by
virtue of the fact that they were just
completing a rebellion against a
tyrannical government and so I guess the
theoretical line would be drawn and what
weapons would be sufficient to protect
the
individual which is the ultimate
minority from an oppressive regime and
and and therein we can have a whole
other program worth a debate where that
line is but you're not calling for a
wholesale change at the Second Amendment
to accommodate that I'm calling for the
recognition of the underlying purpose of
the Second Amendment it had nothing to
do with the right to hunt it had nothing
to do with the right to shoot
recreationally it had to do with
ensuring that the populace was never
subjugated by an oppressive regime let's
go to this is Augusta Georgia Republican
line Ralph
good morning go ahead yes I understand
that
twenty-three other people were came in
with the New York City Charter prepares
these people possibly test themselves
I'd like to know what happens to these
people are they reported are they
monitored in fact if they stay in the
United States and I also like to know
about the wife and children as I
understand she had 24 year-old wife and
three children if I stay in the United
States are they put on welfare how they
are back in the loop okay we talked
earlier about immigration and sort of
conducting it as it relates to the needs
of the team the team being the United
States the first responsibility of
national government is to the nation
it's not to the citizens of one color or
one faith it's to the citizens of the
nation and I think that if you look at
the people on the diversity visa program
there's an incredible disproportion
number of people who are on federal
assistance and I don't think you get any
rewards for good intentions now having
said that every single person who has
been bestowed citizenship or even legal
residents can avail themselves of the
rights to things like due process I
don't want to see that change in their
reaction to a horrific but isolated
event we have rights they're entitled to
due process there are no do-overs where
we allow someone in the country and go
well we think you might be bad you got
to go we need to have demonstrable
evidence to that end having said that to
the best of our ability within the
parameters established by the founders
as it relates to our rights to privacy
and reasonable expectation
search-and-seizures cetera we're trying
to find the bad folks and weed them out
having said that
we have not yet gotten the perfect
paradigm and I am afraid that if we ever
did create a circumstance where there
were no acts like this which I'd love to
see that we wouldn't like what the what
the freedoms were and the and the
privacy and the rights that we had to
sacrifice to get there so it is a
balancing act I think he was Franklin he
said that those who would sacrifice
liberty for security deserve neither and
will lose both what we need to do is do
everything within our legal power to
protect the American citizens while it's
not eroding the very freedoms that make
us unique we are running out of time but
I do want to get your thoughts on the
election in Virginia yesterday and if it
pretends anything for Republicans
overall heading into 2018 now you know
anyone who says it doesn't pretend
anything in the grand scheme I think
he's got their head in the sand what we
saw was about a three through 400,000
vote or Delta from 2013 gubernatorial
election an upward increase in fact
every one of the delegates that lost
yesterday the Republican delegates that
lost actually got more votes than he did
in 2013 which means that you can say
well the Trump voters didn't show up
they showed up but there was a wave of
passion amongst the Democrats now how do
I address it on how much time we have I
think the Republican Party needs to
focus on a Liberty message you can't
explain to me in a manner sufficient to
for me to like it why the federal or
state government tells cancer patients
and doctors what medicines they can
choose you can't explain to me from a
from a Liberty context why and I carried
the bill in Virginia that removed the
government from our bedrooms there are
laws that prohibit people adults with
consent from aging whatever activity
they choose in their bedroom that is
overreach the government the Republican
Party will win when we focus on
individual liberty message knowing that
the ultimate minority is the individual
and we're gonna start bringing in
younger voters and newer voters but
until then there is a there's an energy
gap and the Democrats are winning Tom
Garrett of Virginia thank you for your
time
thank you it's been a pleasure coming up
we will speak to journalist and author
dan Rather who joins us to discuss his
new book what unites us that
conversation coming up next
[Music]
fifty years ago the United States was at
war in Vietnam and this Veterans Day
weekend American history TV on c-span
three looks back with 48 hours of
coverage starting Saturday at 8:00 a.m.
Eastern were live from the National
Archives among the backdrop of three
Vietnam era helicopters to talk with
veterans who flew them then from 11:30
a.m. to 1:00 p.m. we're taking your
phone calls and tweets live with
historians mark atwood lawrence and
leanne hang when about the war in 1967
at 1:00 p.m. from Washington DC's
Vietnam Veterans Memorial a ceremony
featuring remarks by former defense
secretary Chuck Hagel and memorial
designer Maya Lin on Sunday at 4:00 p.m.
Eastern on real America a 1967 CBS News
Vietnam war special report whether it's
due to the enemy's clever tactics or the
fat fighting conditions the weather or
the terrain it seems clear that the
American military offensive along the
DMZ has bogged down like the Marines and
the mud in conch and then at 6:00 on
American artifacts well tour the
National Archives exhibit remembering
Vietnam and at 8:00 on the presidency
the 1967 President Lyndon Johnson
Vietnam War press conference made our
statement to the world of what we would
do if we had communist aggression in
that part of the world in 1954 we said
we would stand with those people in the
face of common danger and the time came
when we had to put up or shut up and we
put up and we're there watch the Vietnam
War fifty years later this weekend on
American history TV on c-span three
c---span were history unfolds daily in
1979 c-span was created as a public
service by America's cable television
companies and is brought to you today by
your cable or satellite provider
Washington journal continues joining us
from Philadelphia Dan Rather the
president and CEO of news and guts and
the author of what unites us reflections
on patriotism good morning to you sir
good morning thank you very much for
having me today what compelled you to
write a book and why do you think it was
needed
well what compelled me to write the book
was a realization that we've become so
divided and so in concrete in very
partisan political and extreme
ideological positions that the country
is some peril I'm not shouting that
we're about to decline and disintegrate
but there are troubling signs in in the
country that number one we're becoming
so divided that we could we could slide
into a version of authoritarianism which
would lead to extreme nationalism
economic nationalism racial nationalism
which could lead further decline into
tribalism so you know I care about the
country and I began to ask myself the
question what is patriotism in the
second decade of the 21st century and as
I explored that question I realized I
don't have any great wisdom about it so
my idea was well let's start a
conversation about what patriotism is
and what it isn't and during that
conversation remind ourselves about the
values that have been the cohesion that
have held the country together through
all these years I I fear in my fear and
before I wrote the book was that people
tend to forget the values that have
sustained us over the our history so
that's the reason I wrote the book one
motivation for it was that I'm on social
media now I have my own Facebook page
and have another Facebook page called
news and guts in which I try to bring
some context and perspective and
hopefully a steady reasonable voice to
some of these questions and frankly the
social media site was so successful I
said to myself well maybe there are
other people a lot of other people who
are thinking you up what I'm thinking
about and which is what is patriotism so
I decided to start writing the book and
now it's out 202 7 for 80,000 for
Democrat
Republicans 202 semper 88,000 won and
independence 202 seven four eight eight
thousand two if you want to ask
questions of our guests you can also
post on our Twitter feed at c-span w.j
going into the book mr. Wrather what was
the perception of patriotism and what
did you find out from writing the book
well what I found out from writing the
book is that there is a difference
between patriotism and nationalism they
are not mutually exclusive they overlap
one another but the biggest difference
is that patriotism is humble patriotism
is modest patriotism is grateful for
where we've been grateful for the great
strengths of the country but recognizes
we're not perfect we can't be perfect
but our nation's history is constantly
striving for as the Constitution said a
more perfect union and that led me to
say to myself well I need to think about
my own patriotism because there's a
feeling that patriotism simply a deep
love for your country that is part of it
but the other part of it is to recognize
that we need to keep constantly
improving
whereas nationalism particularly in the
most extreme version some of which have
been preached from some of the most
powerful positions in the country lately
nationalism has a certain conceit a
certain arrogance about it certainly
when it's taken to the extreme
nationalism sometimes can take the
position you know what we may not be
perfect we were as close to perfect as
we're going to get and it were far
superior to anybody else so one big
difference that I learned between
patriotism and nationalism is that
patriotism includes humility humility
doesn't mean that we are constantly
criticizing ourselves but it does mean
we keep questioning ourselves about how
we can make the country ever better as
we go along so did you write this book
mr. Wrather
with a certain administration the Trump
administration in mine where these
thoughts that started coming to you at
the end of the Obama administration know
oh I can't and won't deny that concerns
about where the current administration
particularly the tone of the current
committee
administration was a factor but it
wasn't a motivating factor in the book
is not a polemic it's certainly not a
screed against the Trump administration
in fact President Trump is not even
mentioned in the book what I sought to
do with the book and others learn to
judge whether I was successful or not is
make a book that even the most forceful
the most dedicated Trump supporter could
read the book and naturally have some
disagreements but say themselves hmm you
know that's something to think about
I'll give you an example that one of the
things that that has made America what
it is is a strong sense of empathy
there's a difference between empathy and
compassion but we aren't empathetic
people not in every year of our history
and in every way but empathy is one of
those words I think a lot of people
don't even know the meaning of the word
and I would recommend gently maybe look
it up in the dictionary and particularly
compare empathy with compassion but it's
one of the values that have held us
together dissent dissent has been a very
strong force for good in the country
overall not every dissent in every
decade but dissent is a is a key to who
we are as people and there's a tendency
sometimes to equate dissent with being
unpatriotic so that's an example of the
kind of discussion I think we can have
in the context of the president
administration and I have deep concerns
about the tone of President Trump and
the tone of his administration
it does have some as the senator said in
the previous section has some elements
of demagoguery they have been the so
called dog whistles and wink winks are
two the worst elements of bigotry and
Prejudice are not only racial prejudice
but religious prejudice and that this is
something so sorry about the phone I
normally turn it off I beg your pardon
but when so the book was not designed to
say we're going to jump all over the
Trump administration on the other hand
it's inevitable that some persons
reading the book I hope most people
reading the book will say well now what
do I
think about what's in this book as
compared to what's happening with our
national leadership dan Rather the
author of what unites us I should say
co-author with Elliott Kirchner who is
he sir
Elliott Kirchner is a longtime friend of
mine and compadre but also a fellow
worker he worked with me at CBS News he
and I've been friends for a very long
time and he was an important part of
putting this book together particularly
he's he's very good Elliott and I give
him full credit Elliot Hirshman he's
very good at taking what I say and write
and say Dan you know what this is to
worry this is way too long
or way too boring and sharpening you so
that's been his role our first call for
you comes from Jeremy and Lawrence
Kansas independent line you're on with
Dan Rather Jeremy go ahead thank you
very much and I appreciate the the
effort of this book and I would ask you
mr. Wrather
about the connection between patriotism
and speaking courageous truth you spoke
about dissent and I completely agree
with you and now that we know from this
New Yorker article by Ronan Farrow
talking about the extent that someone
like Harvey Weinstein would go to cover
up sexual predation using Kroll
incorporated a corporate intelligence
organization that was involved with the
security at the World Trade Center on
September 11th and then black cube
straight up ex-mossad officers you
trying to intimidate journalists Jeremy
Jeremy the direct question to our guest
please so myth rather would you talk
about the pressure that's been put on
you to not talk about the allegations
about September 11th pointing out
building seven as a controlled
demolition okay Jeremy we'll leave it
there mr. Wrather you can answer if you
wish right well I felt no pressure
particularly since I left CBS news not
to infer that I felt any pressure when I
was there but I've been away from CBS
News for 12 years on my own news and
guts my news content company is owned
completely by me I answer only to myself
and I have not felt any pressure to in
any direction about nine
I do think that there are a lot of
rumors around a lot of false rumors
about 9/11 but in terms in direct answer
your question I haven't felt any
pressure I don't feel any pressure now
to report anything other than what I
believed to be the truth or to get as
close to the truth as possible that's
where I am that's where I stand and
that's where I'll be going from Indiana
Robert on our Republican line you're
next yes mr. Wrather
we we elect these people into office and
I think that both sides should work
together otherwise this country is not
going to work and you reported the news
years ago it's a lot different than that
it is now we do not get the truth where
everybody is against each other
everybody wants their way but we should
work together and get God back in this
country mr. Wrather well I certainly
agree and that's one of the fundamental
pieces of the book what unites us that
we are a new experiment in history
there's never anything like the United
States in the whole history of the world
the idea that we could have a country
that's a strong mix of racial religious
ethnic differences and have our
differences but hold ourselves together
United we understand that you know
divided we fall
united we stand it's a fundamental
that's held our country together but in
the present environment and as you point
out the environment in which so often
you have elected officials to take the
position don't bother me with the facts
I have my mind made up and I don't get
into false equivalency here but there's
some of this in both parties and your
point that we have to get along and the
way we get along is to listen to one
another and part of what I've tried to
suggest in united we stand is that we
need a more civil tone from the
leadership and from those of us in the
population as a whole to listen to one
another that doesn't mean give up our
Prince
particularly on such things as racial
bigotry but it does mean to have a civil
tone lower voices listen to one another
and find common ground what works what
makes our system work is a general
proposition of saying listen you and I
may disagree about a hundred things can
we find one thing maybe two things in
which we can reach common ground reach
agreement on things that will help the
country in so many cases what's
happening today is that people want to
do what's good for their own political
futures and for their party and what
we're begging people to do particularly
those in power and the more power they
have the more we need them to do it and
this is a fundamental of what unites us
both in the book and in a larger sense
is we have to get along and the
divisions in the country I think we saw
some of this reflected in the polls and
the vote the Tuesday of this week that
there is a yearning in the country to
hear a better tone to hear more voices
and more action along the lines of we
want to be united rather than
emphasizing divisions and pitting one
race against another in one religion
against another we can't continue in
this country I'm soapbox about it I'm
not trying to preach about it but we
know somewhere deep within us that we
can't hold ourselves together unless
we're willing to get along and getting
along frequently is trying to reach
common ground you give a little I go
level and we reach a piece of
legislation and have it signed by the
president that will help the country if
you go to as using guts website you can
see the governor-elect The Virginian
Ralph Northam on that website it tell us
a little bit about news and guts sir
well when I got into social media I was
very slowly to get into social media
Facebook and Twitter and that kind of
thing what I found was that there was an
audience for the position of folks I'm
not the smartest guy around far from it
but I've been around a long time
I've been a few places and let me try to
put some context in perspective into the
news with a steady and reliable voice so
when I started doing Facebook my own
personal Facebook page I did find that
there was an audience of that so then we
established also on Facebook news and
guts a different page which expands so
on each day's news and tries to point
out what we believe to be the most
important news stories in this day and
add some perspective in context with it
so that's what the news and guts
Facebook site is news and guts is also
the name of my news company which I own
and operate completely a news company
that tries to develop a strong news
content this is from Nashville Tennessee
Robert Republican line best to you
mister rather love what you've done all
these years your reaction to the
question of why 9/11 happened when you
are on top and David Letterman which
essentially was you did not know why
that happened represents the disconnect
that the American people have with our
role or our perception of the role in
the world for example when George Bush
and the Senate led us into Iraq it was
an abuse of patriotism that george w
bush had so much support that we allowed
along with the neocons to get us into
iraq which is a trap and the same thing
the freedom of speech to be able to
criticize our government and foreign
governments for example the 3.8 million
that goes to israel every year and the
best way to stop terrorism is to get
control of israel and their abuse of the
people and in this country folks are
have a hard time expressing that without
being smeared as smeared and demonize
okay robert from nashville mr. robert
mr. Wrather if you wanted to respond
well that there's a lot of in that
question we could spend the rest of the
day discussing a good deal of it uh one
of the points I'm making in the book
what's your nicest I'm not sure it's
stated to fight this directly but number
one going into Iraq by any reasonable
analysis was a strategic disaster of
historical proportions and we in this
country and that night at much of the
world would be paying price for it for a
very long time
now I acknowledge in what unites us that
I along with a lot of other people in
the press did not ask enough questions
as we were going as we were being taken
into the Iraq war we didn't ask enough
tough questions and that was that was a
mistake on my part on the part of much
of the press the question now when we
consider well what unites us and what
can you do going forward is to keep in
mind some of the things you just said
that a free and independent truly
independent fiercely independent when
necessary press is the red beating heart
of freedom and democracy one of the
roles of the press is to be a check on
power and to ask the tough questions
follow up with tough questions don't be
afraid to ask the tough questions what
frequently happens and it didn't happen
in their roll up to the Iraq war and
during the Iraq war is that those in
power may made the case and it was
believed by many people that to question
the strategy of going into Iraq was
somehow unpatriotic just the opposite
was true the patriotic thing to do was
to say I love my country I am going to
back us fighting men and women any time
they're put in danger far afield but as
a member of the press I'm going to ask
the tough questions that was the
patriotic thing to do is the patriotic
thing to do now you write in the book
that you are in the section about the
press saying that and when it comes to
the institution of a free press in
America it's in a state of crisis
greater than I have ever seen in my
lifetime what do you base that on well I
base that on what
the president has said and done that no
president every president we've ever had
has had his difficulties with the press
however we've never had a president and
this includes during the Nixon years
we've never had a president who
personally Oh relentlessly attacked the
press and some both individual members
of the press and press institutions
saying such things as you know member
this is a paraphrase but an accurate one
members of the press are among the most
despicable people in the country and
that members of the Free Press or
enemies of the people that kind of
rhetoric from from the president's own
mouth has we've never had that before in
the Nixon administration President Nixon
had that attitude to some degree but he
always used surrogates so the reason I
say that where the press is in a crisis
the likes of which I have not seen is
because that's what the facts dictate
when the president singles out
individual reporters you recall during
the campaign when there was a reporter
who had physical challenges and the
president mocked him this is unworthy of
any presidential candidate much less a
president himself and the president
threatening press institutions he's
preppies threatened the Washington Post
rather repeatedly because he doesn't
like what what they're reporting and I
think most Americans and this would
include most certainly many of the
people who still support President Trump
you know the tone of the presidency
toward a free press accounts for a lot
because of the power of the presidency
the president has tremendous power
through regulatory agencies and that
sort of thing to exert pressure on the
press so the president is clearly openly
and blatantly trying to intimidate the
press not to do in deep digging
investigative reporting not to ask the
tough questions and his relentless
attacks on the press are unprecedented
in American history there's never been
anything like it
this is not normal
this is unique and in the medium and
long run is very dangerous for the
country independent line Pensacola
Florida Frank go ahead yes I would like
to ask that Republicans are all getting
on and they are carrying the
Constitution in their pockets and they
say we need to go back to the
Constitution the way of sounding fathers
wrote it but to me they are leaving out
all the amendments because if you look
at the original Constitution only white
men poppy owners were allowed to vote
women were not allowed blacks were not
allowed and when they say that we need
to go back to the Constitution I look at
it that we need to make to go to our
Constitution hell that gives everybody
the rights
ok thanks Frank mr. Wrather well this is
a good point and it brings up one of the
chapters in the book is about descent
and how important a principled descent
has been in progress of the country and
the caller mentioned a couple of
instances I like to use the instance of
women's right to vote
you know when women started talking
about this in the 19th century they were
dissenting saying listen women should
have the right to vote they were
castigated very wide widely they were
sometimes called unpatriotic but that
dissent eventually resulted it wasn't
until the first fifth of the 20th
century but it eventually resulted in
women getting in the boat there's been a
time after time when this was the case
when principled dissent was seen as
radical if not indeed unpatriotic but it
turned out over a period of years to be
a way to advance the country to make us
a more perfect union we're never going
to be completely perfect we have to keep
striving to do it and when I wrote this
book what unites us I wanted to put a
chapter about dissent in it for exactly
the reason that the caller pointed out
that it's very American it's deep in our
it
to want to keep improving the country
and we can't continue to improve the
country when we listen to the voice of
leaders who say listen we want to return
to yesterday we want America to be the
America of the 1950s and by the way in
the 1950s we had our problems we were
imperfect during that time but even if
you could go back to some previous time
in our history Minh even if you wanted
to go back you couldn't do it the
demographics of the country has changed
tremendously that we are a richer mix if
you will of diverse religions and races
and ethnic heritage than we've ever been
so any thinking citizen who stops and
thinks about it knows that this talk
about well let's return to some glory
quote glory days if yesterday is frankly
just a way of trying to manipulate
public opinion for something that
realistically is not going to happen we
have to look forward and we have to look
forward united we are just about done
with our guests but keep our New Jersey
Republican line the Edward goai in with
your question or comment please yeah
just wanted there anyway to address a I
guess the empathy with the economic
divide between people in this country I
think is a big factor and I guess Thank
You mr. Wrather well I think there is a
way to get it with with the economic
divide and that is again for us take a
deep breath lower our voices dedicate
ourselves to being civil with one
another we can and recognize that we
have a problem we have a deep and
getting deeper economic divide in which
those at the lowest end of the economic
scale in many cases are getting worse
off and those in the middle economic
strata which sometimes called the middle
class is shrinking and sinking down
while the most wealthy members of the
society yet ever Richard we all know
that this is the situation what we
haven't had and
leadership is leaders who say we
recognize